hello youtube chess lovers my friends
this is gunjan here
welcome to the 16th episode of dirty
chess tricks
now as per the request from many of my
subscribers in this episode i'm going to
concentrate on some of the nice streak
against the french defense
french defense arises after the moon
order e4 e6 and here when white plays
the move d4 black responds with the move
d5
the reproduction i'm going to suggest is
a very very tricky one it not only
contains a lot of tricks but many french
player
get bamboozled just in the opening phase
the line i'm proposing is
two nights attack so you can place
either of the knights for example let's
say knight to f3
and after the usual french motor that is
d5
you play the move knight to c3
so most of the french players are
already in a confusion state because i
found with my own experience that they
don't know how to play against this line
as you can see i have highlighted by the
arrows black has plenty of choices
the move which i'm going to concentrate
in this lecture is the c5
in my next episode i am going to show
you some amazing tricks in other
variations
so let's consider the move c5 which is a
very obvious response from the black
side
but here
just in the third move black has
committed a big mistake
yes you heard it right just on the third
move and it's amazing that white can
quickly exploit this weakness and get a
winning position
now the few moves of the white is very
forceful one and that's what i like
about this line so here white plays
e captures d5
and after obvious response that is e
captures d5
white has another forcing move that is
bishop to b5 check
and now black response is forced
especially if you are playing bullet or
blitz game there are likely to be
chances that your opponent played this
move that is bishop to d7
which is outright mistake
the easiest reputation is
you play queen to e2 check and no matter
how black responds for example let's say
black plays queen to e7 then you can
simply get a pawn after bishop captures
knight captures
and knight captures d5
so bishop to d7 is not possible at this
point that means black response is
forced black has to play knight to c6
afterwards white will continue with the
move queen to e2 check
now as i have highlighted over here
black has three responses
amongst them bishop to e7 is the most
common one
but we'll see what will happen if black
plays other moves
so the first move i want to consider is
bishop to e7
well after this white has a super
aggressive reply
starting with the move knight to e5 so
hitting the knight and once again black
response is force
black has to play queen to d6
if you play bishop to d7
then he fall into our wonderful trick
and the tricks start with the move
knight captures d5
so white is a clear pawn up
and the tactical justification of this
line is after knight captures
queen captures
bishop captures
white regained his peace after knight c7
check
king to f8 and now knight captures
bishop
so not only we are pawn up but black
king is clearly misplaced
so you can see this line is very
forceful and black has to play very
accurately to avoid a lot of tricks
okay queen to d6
and now a super aggressive move that is
d4
black is in big trouble
well what's the idea of d4 that is very
simple what white wants to do is white
wants to capture the c5 pawn and when
black recapture
white wants to play bishop e3 and that
way it will not only speed up the wide
development but it will create an
isolated d-pawn on the black cam which
can be easily exploited in the middle
game
now i reached this position many times
in my games and there are four main
replies played by the black
by the way
to tell you the surprise value of this
line
i checked this position in mega database
2016 and this is what i come up
so far this position reached five times
in real games
and
in all these five games three games
white one and two has been drawn
the reason why i have given the name
subtooth trick
that is this line was played first by mr
subtooth
and he crushed his opponent within few
moves
i also come to know about this trick
when i actually fall into this trick
one of my heritage opponent played this
line against me i was black at this
position
and
i thought for a while in this position
and i thought okay the best response is
you have to accept this phone so the
first response we are going to look at
is c captures d4 which i played in my
game
and here my opponent reveal his nasty
idea that is
bishop to f4
so now once that night moves then there
will be nasty discovery on the queen
once again i have to thought for a long
time and i thought
okay
well if white wants to sacrifice his
material then
let him justify what he get
so i accept this p sacrifice that is d
capture c3
my opponent plays knight capture c6
and i grab another piece because i don't
have any choices so i capture this
bishop
my opponent capture the bishop and
there's a discover check to the king and
kindly note the king has the only place
to go that is
king to d8 because if king to f8 then
after knight to g6 it's not only for
king king and a queen but there's a
checkmate in one
any pawn capture let's say f captures
then queen to e8 and
checkmate majesty
so that was happened in the subtooth
game
well we should see what happens after
king to d8 well after king 2d8
white has the simple reply that is
knight captures d5
so not only attacking the queen but we
have a checkmate 38 on 8.
in this game
i have to play the only reply that is
queen to d2 check my opponent capture
the queen and after pawn captures and
king captures i found to my horror that
i'm upon down
with
virtually no compensation
so this is what you have to do when you
opponent greedily capture all the pieces
okay the second move here black and try
is knight to f6 but this is a big
mistake idea of black is to castle on
the king side but here white can diffuse
everything with the same idea that is
bishop to f4 and now that queen has a
lot of problem
so for example if black castle at this
point then the simplest replies knight
captures queen captures
knight captures e7 check
king to h8 and after knight to d5
not only hitting the queen but at this
point white is a clear piece up
so developing moves such as knight to f6
is not going to help black at all
let's look at some of the critical reply
by black
the first one is bishop to d7
well after bishop to d7 we are going to
continue with the move bishop captures
knight and now there are two ways black
and recapture
if b captures c6 then the simplest is
you are taking the spawn hitting the
queen and if black doesn't capture the
pawn then we are going to consolidate
this pawn with the move b4 so black has
to accept this
and now the simple but very effective
move
knight captures d7 which draw black king
in the center that is king captures and
after queen to g4 jack
king to e8 queen captures g7
bishop to f6 and queen to g3
white emerge with
clear pawn advantage
if bishop captures c6 at this point then
you continue with the move castle on the
king side and after the move knight to
f6
you simply play the move bishop to f4 so
once again the similar idea
a black escape from the pin which is
queen to d8
then the simplest is you capture the
spawn
and now black cannot capture the spawn
because of the discover check of the
knight so black has to castle first but
then we can simply consolidate our pawn
with the move b4 not only white emerged
with a pawn advantage but black has an
isolated pawn on the d5
so that was about bishop to d7 now let's
consider the most critical reply by the
black that is a6
well against this i'm recommending that
you should continue with the move
pawn captures c5 queen captures now you
play the move bishop to a4
now if black continue with the moon
knight to f6 then white has a wonderful
move that is bishop to e3 and later on
white can exploit the isolated d5 pawn
so accordingly there are two critical
replies
the first one is d4
well after this what will go with this
critical sequence that is knight to d3
attacking the queen
queen to a5
black is trying to pin over knight
no matter we continue with the move b4
so queen to d8
and now the simplest is you go with the
moon knight to e4
after further developing moves such as
bishop to e6
castle on the king's side knight to f6
and knight to c5
black has to withdraw his bishop back to
c8 otherwise he is going to lose the b7
pawn
and in all these cases black has an
isolated pawn
and far behind the development
so d4 doesn't work
the most critical reply over here is b5
but after this
i'm proposing a very simple solution
that is
knight catch c6
kindly note queen capture c6 is not
possible because the simplest reply yep
knight captures b5
and the best move engine suggests is
king f8 which is rubbish
okay so what happens if b captures a4
well against this i'm recommending a
simple solution that is knight captures
bishop knight captures
and now
simple move castle
so idea is to play a rook to e1
now if black castle at this point then
black is going to lose the pawn
so obviously black has to find a better
way and
the best move over here is a3
well against this i'm recommending
following sequence that is knight to e4
hitting the queen
queen to d4 hitting two spots
but here comes the forcing sequence that
is bishop to g5
f6
rook to e1
castle on the king side
and now b3
supporting the knight
and after f captures g5 queen captures
knight
yes material is balanced but this is not
the kind of situation black wants
because his all pawns are crippled
so that's pretty much you need to know
against bishop to e7 now let's look at
some of the other sideline replies by
black the first one i want to look at is
knight g to e7
but you can already see the blocking the
dark square bishop is not a good idea by
black and here white can simply continue
with the moon d4
attacking the pawn and after c captures
d4 knight captures d4 we are attacking
the knight
two time so black has to defend with the
move bishop to d7 and now we are going
to simply play the move bishop to e3
i reach this position two times in my
game and these are the two moves tried
by my opponent so the first move i want
to consider is g6 after g6 i continue
with the move castle on the queen side
and after the move bishop to g7
which is a blunder move can you spot the
refutation
yep it's knight catches d5
the game continues with the moon knight
captures
knight captures
pawn captures
and bishop to c5
my opponent has to forcefully block it
with the move bishop to e6 afterwards
bishop to c6
nab the queen and the game
the second move is a6 but after this you
can play the move bishop to e4 and after
the move b5 i simply played the move
bishop to b3 pressurizing on d5 square
my opponent here continue with the move
knight captures d4 i captured the piece
and now he played the move bishop to e6
but then i simply played the move rick
to d1
and look at the funny picture of the
black king side that is hardly any piece
can move
that's the beauty about this line
okay the last move is bishop to e6
well
computers say this is the best move but
i have a doubt because white always have
the moves such as knight to d4 knight to
g5
not only getting the bishop pair but
destroying the black pawn structure
so let me show you some of the sample
games
here i'm proposing that you should
continue with the move as usual d4
there are three choices
in the first one black capture this pawn
which is a mistake
here white will continue with the moon
knight captures d4 so hitting two sports
black defended with the queen to d7 and
now you simply castle on the king side
the problem over here is when black
tried to finish his development let's
say knight to f6
we play bishop to g5 and after bishop to
e7
we have this wonderful move
rook to e1
and
at least what will gain upon so after a
long time
my opponent played the castle
which gave me opportunity to get a pawn
after following sequence that is night
captures pawn captures queen captures
queen captures rook captures
king to f7 and now rook to e1
with a clear advantages position
so cd4 is not working let's look at
another developing move such as bishop
p7 or knight to f6
well i'm afraid they are not good as
well after bishop to e7 you continue
with the move d capture c5
and now if black doesn't capture the
pawn then we can consolidate with the
move b4
so black has to play the move bishop
capture c5 afterwards we can simply hit
this bishop with the moon knight to e4
kindly note if bishop to b6 then we can
capture this bishop and after queen
captures we can play the move knight to
g5
with a very pleasant advantage
so that means bishop has to drop back to
e7 we can continue with the moon knight
to d4
so hitting the knight hitting the bishop
and if queen moves either d7 or d6 then
we can simply castle on the king's side
and place our rook on e1
and get a simple pawn
so my opponent decided to play bishop to
d7
here after some thinking i continue with
the move bishop captures knight
he recaptured my piece and same time
hitting my knight so i dropped my knight
back to the c3
he played knight to f6
which allowed me to pressurize his
bishop with the moon knight to f5
my opponent continued with the mu g6
but then i simply reply with the move
bishop to g5
and my opponent captured the piece but
after bishop captures
rook to g8 and castle on the queen side
it's a horrible horrible position for
black
not only the d5 pawn is a tag but that
bishop need constant protection
the last move i want to consider is
knight to f6 afterwards white will
continue with the moon knight to g5
hitting the bishop and after queen to d7
we can play the move bishop to e3
so pressurizing the c5 pawn
in this game my opponent continues with
the move capturing the pawn i recapture
with the bishop
and now he plays the move bishop to e7
so his idea is to castle on the king's
side
no matter i continue with the castle on
the queen side and after he castle on
the king's eye
i played the simple but very effective
move
rook to even
and now black is going to lose a bomb
so you can see this line has a
tremendous bite and i catch a lot of
high rank player with this simple but
very effective tricks
i hope you enjoy and learn this
wonderful trick against the french
defense
feel free to like subscribe and comment
on this video and i meet you in my next
episode very soon bye
oh my god this is disaster for black but
to my surprise
black plays this amazing move which is
knight cross c6
but this is the last time he is going to
put this
because after knight captures d6
is smartest mate